military investigators are trying to
learn why c-130 cargo plane being flown
to retirement suddenly just plunged to
the ground
Wednesday's crash killed nine members of
the Puerto Rico National Guard this is
the latest in a string of military
aircraft accidents David Martin is at
the Pentagon with more on this story
David good morning good morning the
investigation into what caused
Wednesday's crash is just beginning
but it's hard not to think that planes
aids played a role that particular
aircraft was built in 1965 and was one
of the oldest in the airforce the final
flight of this c-130 was never supposed
to end like this a dive into the ground
and a fireball all those aboard never
had a chance we have confirmed that nine
Airmen in the Puerto Rico Air National
Guard were aboard the aircraft the plane
had just taken off from Savannah Georgia
bound for Arizona where it was to be
retired in an aircraft boneyard this
after a career which included ferrying
supplies to survivors of some of the
Caribbeans worst hurricanes it was a
tragedy for the island of Puerto Rico
which declared nine days of mourning for
the nine victims for the Pentagon it was
the latest in a string of deadly
accidents which have claimed 25 lives in
less than two months and left leaders
like the Commandant of the Marine Corps
searching for answers there's not one
single thing that's the you can't say
it's because of this an analysis of
accident data obtained by Military Times
found a nearly 40% increase in accidents
since 2013
that's when congressional spending
limits known as sequestration went into
effect and by one estimate cost the
Pentagon 147 billion dollars over five
years
that forced cuts in training and
maintenance at the same time aircraft
were in increasingly high demand for
operations like the bombing campaign
against Isis sequestration has ended for
now but chief pentagon spokesperson Dana
White says there are no quick fixes when
it comes to aircraft safety you can't
then you can't buy the training hours
back the fatal crashes get the public
attention but the rise in accidents was
due to relatively minor mishaps in which
no one was killed but the aircraft have
to be taken out of service for repairs
which means fewer planes and fewer
flying hours for pilots who start to
lose their skills
John David things is the human end of
all these sometimes abstract
conversations we have about budget